it's my pleasure tonight to introduce Dr
lar Larry a Dr Arn is the 12th President
of Hillsdale College where he is also a
professor of politics and history he
received his ba from Arkansas State
University and his ma in PhD in
government from The Claremont Graduate
School he also studied at Worster
College Oxford University where he
served as a director of research for sir
Martin Gilbert the official biographer
of Winston Churchill from 1985 to 2000
he served as president of the Claremont
Institute for the study of statesmanship
and political philosophy he serves on
several Boards of directors and he
previously served on the US Army war
College Board of visitors for two years
for which he earned the department of
the Army's outstanding civilian service
medal in 2015 he received the Bradley
prize from the lind and Harry Bradley
Foundation
a member of numerous organizations
including the Church Hill Center he is
the author of three books Liberty in
learning the evolution of American
Education the founders key the Divine
and natural connection between the
Declaration and the Constitution and
what we Risk by losing it and most
recently Church Hills trial Wiston
Churchill and the salvation of free
government please welcome Dr Larry AR
thank you dear Anita the brains of the
fome
outfit I'm tempted to say the brains of
the external Affairs department at
hillso college but thank you also Doug
Jeffrey
for taking credit for all of Anita's
work uh thank you George Gilder and Paul
Ray and all you speakers uh you guys
were great art laugher was great uh I
confess I didn't see anybody but art
laugher and the reason is uh two of my
faculty members got married last night
to each other and um it's very sweet and
I'm an old man now and I hir them both
and I'm watching their careers go and
they're actually
opposites and you think I mean that one
of them is a man and one of them is a
[Applause]
[Laughter]
woman and that that does turn out to be
the
case but no one of them is a lit
professor and a poet and one of them is
a mathematician
and it's the oddest thing I ever saw in
my
life when they talk it's like it's what
is it it's like somebody speaking the
wrong language all the time and yet they
have like uh Moone eyes at each other
all the time and these are you know
faculty members at Hills College they're
pretty fancy pants
people so that's why I was not here how
many faculty members are in this room by
the way
a lot yeah
wow are you any
good I'm in I'm a judge of that you know
that's who I work with I like faculty
members and if I don't I kill
them okay um so Doug Jeffrey or Anita or
somebody has assigned me the topic
property rights and religious liberty
and so I'm going to say four things one
is why
Christians might and often do think that
property rights and commerce is
unchristian uh going along with that why
a lot of people think that
uh if you just protected property rights
that would be
enough um the second is both of those
people are
wrong and the third one is what James
Madison thought about that and the
fourth one is what Winston Churchill
thought about that so I'll say those
things um first of all why would you
think that um CS Lewis whom I admire
very greatly in Mere Christianity says
at one point that uh he's he's
illustrating this point he's
illustrating the point that if you
follow the the New Testament and the
teachings of Jesus you'll get a
description of a life that none of us
would
like
uh uh liberal people I don't think he
uses liberal and conservative but
liberal people he says might not like
how straight laced it was about sexual
matters thank God we've arised at the
straight laced age about sexual matters
today he said but uh conservative people
might not like how sort of socialistic
or left it was on economic
matters and uh read Pope Francis right
what does he
say uh Commerce seems different than
praying doesn't it it's uh grubbing and
uh we're after our
self-interest and uh it might even be
seen as the difference between charity
and exploitation and many do see it that
way of course
um KL Marx you're all readers of Karl
marks of
course and certainly I
am he defends Christianity some he's
famously atheist I know and militant
against it
but has not Christianity declaimed
against private property against
marriage I guess he means the Apostle
Paul against the state has it not
preached in the place of these charity
and poverty copy and mortification of
the flesh monastic life and mother
Church Christian
socialism is but the holy water with
which the priest cons consecrates the
heart burn heart burnings of the
Aristocrat you see what he's saying he
likes the spirit of it some right this
other worldliness this don't look after
yourself look Beyond yourself
right so there have been in history lots
of Christian
people uh I've uh just spent the last
few months uh in the
unfortunate trial of reading about the
founding of the of the labor party in
Britain Churchill hated it and said a
lot of things about it so I thought I'd
better have to go read them and see if
what he said was true or not and uh you
know a big strain of the founding of
socialism in Britain was
Christianity and there were two kinds of
the strain one Sounder than the other I
think one was you know Jesus says take
care of the
poor better go do
that this is the
way the other one says
uh the important thing about Jesus is he
came down to
earth Heaven is here now we're supposed
to build heaven here on
Earth we can do that now and this is the
way let's be so socialist lots of
Quakers in particular a couple of books
assert I found some myself who who
thought
that so it doesn't matter that the
Socialists were by and large
atheists lots of Christians took up with
them and there was some purpose to
it it's a strain today although if you'd
looked 10 years
ago you would have said uh
uh the heart of the leftward movement in
the American government is a claim
against
property the claim goes this way
um the divisions Among Us are so deep
and that's because we don't come out the
same and if we don't come out the same
in one generation we won't come out the
same in the next and so we've got to do
something about that and at the core of
the issue is
property and so we we should protect
property rights and the others will be
fine lots of people thought that
too so that's the second bunch I talked
about right some Christian people
thought why do we have to support all
this money grubbing and some other
people
thought if we could just do something
about property we could leave the rest
of it
alone that's a strain big time the
progressives in America W Wilson and
people like that they were very much of
that view get the money
right now I'll tell you why that's
foolish
um the formidable people who've been
enemies of the right to property are
formidable precisely because they
understand better than that what do they
understand they understand that we are
this odd Integrity of soul and
body and they have this idea they mo
most of the best of them Marx for
example is a clear sighted about this if
you like the way the human being is
organized then you're going to have to
protect it
all and if you don't like it you're
going to have to change it
all Mark said
uh
whatever he said I can't find
it what did he
say I give you the sense of it he said
it stands to
reason in the Communist Manifesto he
writes this it stands to
reason that if we were going to
interrupt an ages long institution of
pro property we would have to uproot
every tradition that exists he says that
that's what we're going to
do 10 years later in the Fabian 20 years
later in the Fabian essays in Britain
written by George Bernard Shaw and the
people who founded the labor
party what they say in there is they
say we're just going to deal with
property nothing
else
it's not about sex it's not about family
it's not about religion it's just about
this one
thing but you know they spoil the case
because first of all you know Mark said
of the family the uh the children and
wives are the wage slaves of the wage
slaves the most degraded Among
Us uh treated worse because their bosses
their immediate bosses the fathers and
the husbands
are themselves slaves and they pour it
on those below them and so we have to
wipe that out says Marx that's what he
says what the fabians say is no we don't
have to do that but then they say uh in
the Fabian essays they say but you know
what will change the
situation if every man woman and child
is guaranteed an equal
income and then they say is it really
efficient for us to eat our meals in
small groups in our
houses is that the way we should do it
wouldn't it be more
efficient if we had some more communal
way of doing it it may be a long time
writes Sydney
web when before we can no longer say
that a man's home is his
castle so you see what I think is if you
read George Bernard Shaw and intelligent
woman's guide to socialism capitalism
and something else he says in there uh
we don't really have anything to say
about
marriage except they're not going to be
these metaphysical Affairs anymore we're
not going to think of it like that you
see so big things are at
stake and doesn't it stand to reason
that they would be at stake because what
in fact are our lives
like uh I work in this college and uh
they're all it's very
old-fashioned it's it's really cool come
and see it and um you know the the young
people that was did you hear that laugh
it's the greatest laugh I've ever heard
and her name is Anna
schner she teaches economics now but I
heard that laugh for four years at
Hillsdale College right and I treasure
that dang laugh it's really good and
there's just everything is like that
right and they're all young and they're
all in turmoil and and what's funny
about them is and you know Aristotle
writes about them they really like their
bodies because their bodies are coming
into their own and they're in very good
shape and uh we don't have coed dorms at
our place at least as long as it's legal
to to not have
them there's some question about that
right but you know I I noticed the boys
are
interested
and then they're they're
18 and that's an age
and uh they would say to me I used to
arue we used to AR we have an honor code
now so we don't argue about Much Anymore
they've all agreed before they come and
among the young that's just dispositive
see because they're just at that age
when they need to start making their own
decisions so you can't put rules on them
you just have to make them adopt yours
before they
come it it really does work and it works
even better if you tell them you know if
I were you I wouldn't sign this thing
cuz this is hell and you're not really
going to like it you know and they just
they just ceue up to sign the honor code
right because it's a big exercise of
their independence and they're growing
up and then they vindicate it like crazy
but back before we had that they would
sit and say things like um Dr R what
does it matter to you what we do when we
go to bed at
night sometimes they put it in the
hostel way they'd say what gives you the
right to say you know and I would say
well nothing it's just that there are
2700 colleges in America and you pick
this one
and foolish child what were you thinking
you
know but but that always worked right
but but then they would say more
reasonably they'd say you know what what
does it matter and I'd say well you're
too young to know what sex is
for and they'd say what does that mean
and I'd say it's for you and you know
the boys that dog go oh wow okay you
know that's what I was thinking you
know I'd say uh if I call your parents
and you're 18 19 20 or 21 years old
they're all that at h College if I call
your parents I have learned I don't do
it very often but when I do call them I
say this is Larry iron and everything's
okay and the reason is they turn into
blithering idiots if they hear my name
oh my God you see and I said you know
look how old you are if you were some
other kind of creature your parents
would not know who you
are and I promise if you ever get a
message yourself from my office come to
my office it won't say come to my office
there's something wrong with your
parents cuz you'll
Panic that's what sex is for that it
makes you and then you take God forever
to
raise and if it and if the parents don't
do it we've got data about that now it
doesn't work very well
right
but see that's a problem too if you
think about
it in
uh
188890 let me get my dates right here
you think I'd know the life of Winston
Churchill after 40 Years of studying it
in 1898 Churchill was writing a novel he
finished it in
1899 and in this novel uh there's it's
it's fun you should read it's called
seola but there's this despotic man and
and he's got this beautiful wife and
there's this Republican galvanizing
beautiful romantic leader excellent
public speaker and of course that's
Winston Churchill by another
name and he's interested in the state
that is to say getting the job at this
desperate and he's also interested in
his wife who's a really pretty woman
Lucille is her name
light and
so there's a third Suitor for the state
and the
wife and this is you know Winston
Churchill is 24 years old when he writes
this novel when he was 26 he had fought
in three Wars observed another with
great distinction published two
bestselling books and was the most
widely published essayist and article
writer in the country and then he got
elected to Parliament I mean he puts us
to
shame I always tell our kids you got to
learn to be ambitious when you try to do
this but what he notices is that uh
there's a big rally and he gives a
speech and This president's wife who's
getting sweet on him uh she shows up and
she loves the speech and then she's
coming out and she hears this third
alternative and his name is Carl with a
K and he says you know he's a useful
tool this seola but what does he
understand of the community of
property and then they comrade says
called comrade says or the community of
wives I'd like to have the president's
wife and she shutters
right so do you see there's a kind of
drama going
on uh Churchill actually in the novel
finds a decent and respectable way for
him to get both the state and the
president's
wife uh the president has to abandon his
duty and then she becomes
free but it's interesting thinking like
it like that that is he and then in his
speeches in the first decade of the 19th
century he's always saying you know we
live in this bad age where the family
has become
questionable why would
it why is it questionable in
marks don't you see how unfair it
is it's all wrong because
um anybody here have Rich fathers and
mothers if you did you wouldn't say this
America
but I was well born extremely well
born cuz you know my wife is born to an
old family they have a lineage that goes
back a long way and they know the
lineage and they've been in the same
part of England forever and ever and I
just love that and I even love it that
she's going to kill me for saying this
but it's the gospel I'm telling
you lady gadiva is in her
ancestry and my wife is such a sweet and
naive woman that she told me the story
one time and assured me that she had
ridden through the town in that
condition to protest the treatment of
her husband of the villagers and the
villagers this is the part that's a
little hard to believe so respected her
for doing that that they didn't
look I said well you know I don't know
these particular villagers
but you see but I'm a mongr and on the
other hand my dad went to college first
in his line and he loved to read books
and he was a school teacher and there
was always somebody to read to me and
encourage me to read and there was
always books around to read and there's
always opinions about those
books and that's such a blessing you
know and not everybody gets
that it's not fair is
it Secretary of Education the other day
just before I retired so it's a couple
of months now he said that there's so
many broken homes in the inner city of
course subsidized by government
policy that we're going to have to think
about building dormitories to raise them
in and think about what that means for
the liberal State you see the problem
we're
in if you commit yourself to an
engineering project to make everything
equal what the fabians think is the same
thing the progressives think by the way
they think that the co that the economy
will become infinitely more productive
or massively more productive because we
won't be thinking about competing with
each other so much anymore and our real
creative talents will be liberated they
go on about that line after line after
line you know and what about all the
irrationality and duplication whereas if
we could just plan it on a scientific
basis
and do you see the argument for that
it's the same thing with John Dewey and
all of those guys right the argument for
that is science has revealed to us
something first of all the Natural
Science as bill balberg is telling
George Gilder about how to Frack down
there today and I don't mean anything
dirty by that
expression right and he he he knows how
to do it you know and it's really cool
that we can do it and we got a lot more
stuff than we used to have we got plenty
of it actually and we might not even
need it anymore because other things are
getting cheaper too so it's a Marvel
right science has done that and science
has done that George Gilder writes books
about that right and so in the in the
late 19th century they noticed that
science is doing all that it can
exercise massive power over nature and
so why don't we then just take the
techniques and attitudes
of Science and apply them to the
governance of human
beings and then we can put everything
right we can stop this conflict over
inequality that's the plan that's the
modern plan that's the reason the
government of the United States is a
multiple of its previous size and that's
happened in two generations whereas in
the 10 before it effectively did not
grow although the country grew in
population massively and in
area is that idea that idea that if we
plan things by experts at the center
then we can reduce or remove or
eliminate inequality and therefore
conflict among us and we can make
everything right and then this poverty
and strife and envy can go
away now just so happens when the
Churchill is in
his career who can you think of so I
think the greatest Statesman ever to
live are two Americans and Winston
Churchill it's a controversial claim but
it's everybody recognize their special
Washington and Lincoln and
Churchill interesting that the three
because it's hard to think of anybody in
the ancient world who's the equal of
those
guys maybe there are candidates right
but when you name the candidates then
you start thinking maybe not the
mystically
Pericles Caesar
Augustus Brutus Fabius maximum those
guys right but these
guys they United a nation of
volunteers together and of those three
Churchill is the one who live to see
what I'm describing right
now this application of modern science
to human Affairs which makes a massive
increase in power and is accompanied
right away with the understanding that
in order to make everything better we're
going to have to control everything
about the human
being that's why Marx writes finally
that religion is the sigh of the masses
of their pain and therefore it is their
opium because it it it schools them to
abide their pain instead of do something
about it it puts off a gratification to
the next World which is actually
possible in this
one what does Madison say about it he
says uh in 1792 he wrote an essay called
property and I'm going to read you three
lines from
it it's a beautiful by the way I go look
it
up in this particular application the
term means that Dominion that one man
claims and exercises over the property
means that Dominion which one man claims
and exercises over the external things
of the world an exclusion of every other
individual in its larger and juster
meaning it Embraces everything to which
a man May attach a value and have a
right and which leaves to everyone else
the like
Advantage a man's land or merchandise or
money is his property in the former
sense in the latter sense a man has a
property in his opinions and the free
communication of
them he has a property of peculiar value
in his religious opinions and in the
profession and practice dictated by them
he has a property very dear to him in
the safety and Liberty of his person now
I want you to understand that right it's
a property very dear that you can be
safe that is to say not killed not bound
not in enslaved not harmed that's very
dear he says but now listen to the next
line and he has an equal property to
that you see in the free use of his
faculties and the free choice of the
objects on which to employ
them now do you see what that
means because that's the point that
rings in every corner of the American
Revolution what he writes right there is
Give me liberty and especially Liberty
of the mind or give me
death that's little mild James Madison
writing
that and don't you see that these
property rights correspond most closely
to the animal nature of the human being
but not only to they here's what I mean
we're just like you know we've got these
boxer dogs and they just adore or my
wife and it's they can tell
time because when it's 4:30 they know
it's time for them to pretend it's 5
[Laughter]
o' so they can be fed right and we need
that too or we'll
die and and the property rights if you
can't have property you can't have any
Safeguard against the future and that's
especially important if you have loved
ones who depend on you you see but of
course when I said it's chiefly but it's
not only concerned with that because the
human being is this integrated thing and
isn't it the case that the prime moral
virtues one of them is courage which has
to do with the right disposition toward
pain and danger in other words you
humans hurt as bad as any dog and can
imagine it way better but to be
courageous is not to be dominated by
that there are things for which you must
Li risk your life or be a coward and the
other one is moderation which is the
correct disposition toward pleasure so
you are seduced and tempted all the time
and that means that in Every Act we take
our soul is set up as a judge over our
desires and the testing place we humans
meet
is in this connection between the body
and the soul and we are good or we are
not good and therefore we are happy or
we are unhappy by how we regulate that
and to take away the right to our
property is to deprive us of the ground
upon which we exercise our
Humanity but then the other thing is
exactly the same
thing do you ever have a thought that
moves you to to
cry Lincoln said once if I ever feel the
soul within me expand and Elevate to
those Dimensions that are not Unworthy
of its Almighty
architect what a thought to put into
words if I ever get to thinking I'm just
a little bit like
God and what a grand expansion and
elevation that is and that's something
going on in his own Noggin and his own
soul that's how we know the Divine
that's how we can be responsible to the
Divine that's the respect in which we
are like the Divine it is embedded in
this
body and that means an
attempt because see if we respect these
rights under nature as Madison said it
would be better to die
than to permit anyone to fail to respect
them
all if we are to respect them we're
going to get tragedy of course we are
we're here in this earth uh art laugher
whom I've known him as long as I've
known George Gilder and that's a long
time and I love them both because
they're the same people as when I first
met them I'm an old man now they're not
and uh and I looked up to them you know
and art is exactly the way he was in the
1980s when I saw him debate a bunch of
guys and met him after early 1980s but
you know he said some stuff today that's
just like him and a little bit silly
because exaggerated because what he said
was it was touching what he said about
his family right and you know penny and
I have a son-in-law now and we know he's
okay you can know he's okay because he's
living
still and and art art said I'm ready to
go go right but of course he's not a bit
ready to go why because they're giving
him grandchildren and whatever love he
has for them and you know he can teach
them
economics and and some of them some of
them are only going to know the
reputation of the famous man they never
met and he's going to be sad about
that what if you could make that go away
what if you could perfect that because
don't you understand that that tragedy
that I just named is not known to any
creature on earth except us cuz dogs
don't know it we put them down you know
we have our seventh and eighth boxers
right now and that means there's six of
them that we had to put down and we're
devastated by it but they're
not because they don't know it's coming
right God made them like that and he
made them wonderful things and worthy
things and of course we spoiled them
worse than we spoiled our children which
is saying
something but they're not like us and
how are we able to do that to suffer
that
tragedy except that we have Immortal
Souls in Mortal bodies and the rights of
each are what make up the human
being and we live in an age where
they're trying to get rid of
that Churchill was afraid of War because
he saw this
battle he he fought in the sedan against
the great grandfather of the current
ruler of the North Sudan who was the
founder of what was probably the first
Islamic
Republic chill didn't like those guys at
all read the book he wrote about it it's
beautiful the river War amazingly
mature and he says in there however the
way we killed
them with machine guns and artillery
from a distance and they couldn't it
seemed cruel and unfair to strike them
so hard when they could could not hurt
us at all and then he said you know
courage won't matter as much on a
battlefield anymore as it used to it
used to be the bravest ones tended to
win now it's the one with the weapons
with the tools and so tool making is
everything he had all of those thoughts
before he was 27 years old and wrote
them down and never forgot them and
developed them the rest of his life but
he thought the same thing was going on
in peace
he thought that just like we transformed
our ability to kill each other we are
transforming our ability to despatie
each other his contemporary CS Lewis
wrote in Mere Christianity and said it
on the radio during the second world war
and either what Lewis said on the radio
at that time or what Churchill said in
his speeches were for decades the most
popular thing ever to be on the British
radio and they were contemporary
statements and Lewis says that the power
of man over over nature can only be
expressed as the power of some men over
others Churchill saw the growth of these
great
tyrannies never anything seen like them
before and Churchill thought they were
the same kind of thing the Nazis and the
Communist hated them
both and one of the things he hated
about them was that they took your
children from you and made them
Witnesses against you so your convers
ation around the dinner table was not
safe and you were not to be saying
prayers with those kids why because
independent thinking it's as old as
Aristotle tyranny is hard to make live
because people don't like it it's not
stable and so how can it be made to live
read the fifth book of the politics
because what he says in there is this he
says all they do is they wore down every
excellence in the society
especially they obstruct friendship
among the most excellent people because
if they can degrade everybody they'll
put up with anything and what's going on
go watch the movie or read better read
the book
1984 and what do they what what is their
target it's not just the property it's
all of the qualities that make up the
full integrated human being Churchill
says uh that the
Bolsheviks have uh perfected a kind of
government that is not exactly like the
honey bee because it can't produce any
honey they are governing their people
like white ants like
insects but he also said that's only an
extreme form of something that's growing
up in the
West in 1945 after the election after
the war when he was the greatest living
man he says the Socialist Party and he's
referring now to the people who are in
coalition government with
him after they won that war right and
some of them were war heroes from the
first world war he said they would never
realize their ultimate aims and I
understand they do not intend this but
still it is true they could not realize
their ultimate aims without the use of a
secret police yes I mean a
Gusto cuz see if you really were going
to make people equal as regards results
how will you do that you're going to
have to raise them all the
same in 1931 the year that Brave New
World was published although we know
because of a letter to his wife he did
not read that book until
1958 Churchill says that in an essay
called 50 years hence he says um he says
uh you could see how we're going to get
to a place where we can carry out the
whole cycle of human reproduction in a
laboratory
and if we do that then we won't just
make some of them excellent we might
want to make some of them suited better
just to be
workers so you see this idea of equality
what's it going to give rise
to some are going to dominate
others uh in April in the Wall Street
Journal two Noble uh prize-winning
biologist called for a moratorium on the
alteration of germline DNA because we
can do it
now and we can remove some dirt and
that's the part of DNA we all get makes
us you know the basic human
information and we can eliminate some
birth defects but maybe we could also
make some improvements too but that once
we do
that then the human being is an artifact
of the human
being I'll read you
this in 19 50 years hence Churchill
says I read a book the other day which
traced the history of mankind from the
birth of the solar system to its
Extinction there were 15 or 16 races of
men which in succession Rose and fell
over periods measured by tens of
millions of
years think how long they're
living in the end a race of being was
evolved which had mastered nature a
state was created whose citizens lived
as long as they
chose enjoyed pleasures and sympathies
incomparably wider than our
own navigated the interplanetary spaces
could recall the Panorama of the past
and foresee the
future so you see he's imagining a
Utopia created by
science but listen to this passage which
I think might be the most important he
wrote in his life
what was the good of all that to
them what more did they know than we
know about the answers to the simple
questions which man has asked since the
earliest dawn of reason why are we here
what is the purpose of life whether are
we
going no material progress even though
it takes shapes we cannot now conceive
or however it may expand the faculties
of man can bring Comfort to his soul it
is this fact more wonderful than any
that science can reveal which gives the
best hope that all will be
well nine years later Churchill would be
prime minister of the country and he
would have a proposal for a peace
conference in front of him from musolini
to settle the war
and at that moment Britain was alone and
had eight or 10 divisions and Germany
had
300 and they were threatened to come
across and take the whole
country my wife's
land and he's got that fearsome Prospect
in front of him and he did something
just awesome to stop that from happening
and took responsibility for that and his
argument right the way through was we
are going to beat this man and when we
have done that we are going to kill
him and that's what he
did and it looked hopeless and you
wonder to yourself where would he get
the faith for that why would he think
that I can tell you he hated and feared
War all his life he was the last guy
living to make a speech about fighting
to the death what made him think it was
a good idea
here it was because he was possessed of
the knowledge of the nature of the human
being that we are made in God's image to
confront the Eternal questions from
inside a mortal body and our rights to
our property and our rights to our
religion are just two aspects of the of
the two things that integrate to make
the whole a human
being and Churchill thought that that
was a thing produced by nature and God
and that no man not even Adolf Hitler
could ever face
that and he fought for
that and I think we're going to have to
fight for that
too thank
[Applause]
you
does anybody want to say anything or you
want to go to
bed drinks are on the
house there's
somebody hi my name is Tim mossell from
California Baptist University since you
quoted Lewis uh CS Lewis from the
abolition of man I'm wondering uh what
you think in terms of solutions that CS
Lewis offered especially from his book
um That Hideous Strength it seemed the
solutions weren't particularly this
worldly I wonder if you could comment on
that or are we simply waiting for
another Church Hill that's a great
question and uh so uh CIS leis so here
so I know a few things about CS Lewis's
relationship with Winston Churchill
Churchill offered him a companionship of
the British Empire and Lewis turned it
down in a very Charming
letter uh Lewis also wrote of Churchill
that he called him a great Statesman and
hadn't you noticed that he looked like a
frog and at the time I first read that
I'd never believ that Churchill did look
like a frog but I've seen several
pictures of him now that I understand he
did look like
frog and then uh in 1950 and 51 he wrote
several letters to friends in which he
thought that Churchill was doing a great
job in the election and he was going to
throw the Socialist out so but in his
letter refusing the CBE he said that
mischievous people would think it was a
partisan thing and it's better if I
don't do it so Lewis proposed uh uh
chose not to appear as a partisan
although I think he
was there's even a
record so um that means that it points
toward Churchill's solution which
Churchill which Lewis said Churchill was
Grand and Churchill very much believed
in having a solution to things and he
did so I can tell you what he wanted to
do about war he wanted to avoid it
wherever possible above all with
friendship be friends with everybody you
can stretch the
point
If it threatens and you should be Keen
to see if it threatens you should be
keep a watch out then you should prepare
and the first way reason way to prepare
is to make alliances with other free
peoples especially the English-speaking
ones because we have figured out more
about that than others have he
claimed think about our foreign policy
today and see if there's that coherence
in it alliances are very important
because it brings huge amounts into the
field if they trustworthy
people you know if you want to salute
the country that respects the rights of
Arabs and Muslims in the Middle East you
should be real friendly to Israel
because that's where they get
him so then the next thing is have
overwhelming Force build your weapons in
time and then the third thing fourth
thing is fight your Wars with a strategy
to win the dang things and get them over
as quick as you can and then go back to
peace which is what it's all about
anyway so that's
War what about
peace there are two main things uh three
I guess uh Churchill was a
constitutionalist and that's an odd
thing for a Statesman to
be why because all of us when we
exercise practical judgment what are we
doing why do we get bad consciences why
do we doubt our choices why do we fret
over them as we make make them because
we're confronted with something and we
have to some necessity but we've got
this other thing outside this conscience
that's talking to us about it and so
that's why we could be ashamed and
that's why we something you know like
the dogs there's really only two
phenomena going on to the dogs do they
want it and will I beat them if they get
it right and you know I hardly ever beat
them so gosh they get what they want but
but you see where us we've got this
other thing well the classics teach us
that Statesmen are are people who are
extremely good at that kind of reasoning
and even lethal about it so that's one
kind of thing but what are
constitutions they're big Grand rules
written a long time ago before these
circumstances even
arose and so it's an odd pairing isn't
it so I I will just tell you from long
study think of the great world Statesman
in Winston Churchill's time and you will
find one who was a friend of
constitutionalism and the rest of them
cheaply repudiated it or at least sought
to weaken it so Churchill was for that
make up some big rules that divide Grant
and limit power and follow them because
this age he said the dominating thing
about this age is that there's so much
power that everything should be devoted
to trying to control it so it doesn't
get out of hand other ages might have
been different you know in other ages
people sweated and broke their backs to
try to dig a ditch to get water to their
crops this is not like that in this age
God knows what we can do and we're
likely to do it to each other so the art
in this day is to control the massive
powerful good that we have generated and
the key to that in war is strategy and
the key to that in in peace is
constitutionalism and Churchill was for
those things all the time and it's odd
that second thing because he was such an
Artful and assertive
Statesman Bob roller from isua Pacific
University in California say hi to my
friend Chris flry okay I will
so as I hear what you're talking about I
hear you talking about property rights
essentially that come from the Creator
but there are those in today's society
who teach that property rights or
whatever power whatever politics
whatever the state says they
are uh tell us how to navigate that
difference well thank you um and
uh uh as a follow of Cs l i don't
believe in having an original thought in
my life so uh um I'll quote Abraham
Lincoln to you
um see first of all the what what the
classics teach us and and by the
Classics I include Thomas acquaintance
because I can show you where this
argument is there too we know about the
rightness of things chiefly by sense
perception uh it's it's one reason why I
was talking to David derell why I
college is a good idea and you know
online college is a great idea too but
it's not as good and the reason is we
can see each other we can talk to each
other so what do you see when you see
people
working and and the idea is you can see
that they are productive of their own
livelihoods it's on the basis of that
that Lincoln says God made every man
with one head and two hands and one
mouth and the plan main implication was
that the head was to guide the hands in
the feeding of the
mouth he says the most uh unfortunate
not not unfortunate necessary and tragic
things that he
says say in the Charleston debate and
the Lincoln Douglas debates I am not now
nor have I ever been in favor of the
social and political equality of the
black man if he'd said anything else but
that his political movement would have
been over but then what follows that he
says but you know in her right to eat
the bread that she has earned with the
sweat of her own face she is the equal
of every one of else and equal before
God you see or link or Jefferson in the
last letter he ever wrote he says uh he
says uh he he couldn't go to the he died
on the 50th anniversary declar of
independence of course as did John Adams
but they couldn't go they were old and
creaky and about to die and so Jefferson
wrote a letter saying what did it
mean and he said to Roger Whiteman a few
days before he died and he said it means
that some were not born with saddles on
their backs nor others booted and
spurred to ride them by the grace of God
and so the answer is isn't it in that
language which is the music of America
and which states a truth that is visible
to the naked eye and the words only uh
only serve to make to illuminate and
preserve the truth that all can
observe and and you know I mean I will
tell you since you ask
me I'm a political scientist
um so
um what they might
do anybody who wanted to reform the
government of the United States so it
would protect our rights which I think
it does not do today
uh they might talk about the particular
people and structures that allocate the
right they call it the right to do
things
today you know our College our college
is 171 years old and I you know assert
to you you come and you guys are Judges
it's good it's a very good college and
it's hard and its goodness is is
measured in one thing in the deep dark
circles under their eyes at the end of
every
term right they're all laughing right
and the reason is that ain't
funny we mean it you see it's 171 years
old and the Department of Education was
started in
1979 and they left us off that stupid
scorecard the other day and it's you
know it's just dog stupid the whole
thing but then they say that we're not
we're only certificate granting
institutions and they didn't I think
they looked up Hillsdale in the federal
database and found the Hillsdale beauty
college I think you know I mean that I
think that might have happened but but
the point
is that's ugly right that way of rule
and we should call it
that because people are still people
those who work in the government and US
regular ated by it and if you just take
an opinion poll about who likes that
kind of government you can't find 30%
that'll say they like
it I'd talk about that more if it were
me anymore yeah I'm Tim Barnett from
Jacksonville State University in The
Federalist Papers James Madison argues
repeatedly that um the public good is
the end or goal of the rule of law
do you believe that Liberty and property
function as a hybrid surrogate for the
public
good that's a good
question
um yeah I do and I I'll I'll make an
argument for it the first answer is I
don't know but uh let me make my second
argument so in the 10th Federalist uh
Madison introduc that's the one that's
all about faction and it's supposed to
show that the government is all just
about a big mechanism setting us off
against each other the worst things
about us in at odds with each other will
produce unbeknownst to ourselves some
good that's the way the argument is
caricatured but that's not what it says
what it says is that uh these bad things
are there and if they and to the extent
that they can be made to cancel one
another out then the government will be
liberated to to to serve what he calls
the permanent and aggregate interest of
the
society right permanent and aggregate
that's all of us right but if it's an
aggregation it is all of us but it also
includes each of us and in that
paragraph where he says that for the
first time in the Federalist and I think
that may be the first time that that
phrase is used in political
literature uh when he says that in that
place he he says a few sentences later
that the chief object of government is
to protect the unequal rights that we
have of acquiring
property so I think that makes the
argument that yes is the answer to your
question do you agree with
that I'd have to reflect on
that so you don't know any any more
about it than I
do I bet you're a really good professor
sir okay yes sir thank you for that yes
sir um Bill Penn from B Haven University
I've always heard that
maintaining Liberty and rights is
intricately tied with
responsibility and my question is to
what extent are we failing in teaching
uh basic responsibilities in the home in
the school and um how should we go about
improving this area whereby we can uh
teach responsibility and thus maintain
our rights and
Liberties uh so I I'll say two things
about that uh one is
um
uh there's a line of argument that says
that in the American Revolution and in
modern times in the American Revolution
in particular there there was a shift
away from our duties and
responsibilities to our rights and
that's why we've become such spoiled
babies and
uh I I defy anybody to read the
literature of the American Revolution
and find that in
it uh uh George Washington first
inaugural address and do you understand
that the Constitution of the United
States could not have been written
unless George Washington had agreed to
go to the convention and be the chairman
and that he almost pulled out and so
James Madison squat little guy got on
his horse and rode to Mount Vernon to
talk him into it had to be there
couldn't have created the Office
president but but for him and the reason
is he was morality
walking awesome what kind of guy he
was so he says in his first an article
address where he did have a speech
writer a young man by the name of James
Madison he says our Republic is founded
in the great fact and the whole course
and economy of nature the indis
indisoluble union between virtue and
happiness see you're going to go win
that war beat the greatest military
power on Earth sign your name to a
document of treason when they've already
got a rit in the hands of a general out
to arrest
you you're going to need your
courage and your
moderation you can't find any serious
ious account of the human being that can
say that his rights are only his
wants his rights are his needs and what
are his
needs above all we need the good and we
need God you see so I don't I first of
all that won't work and and and there's
no one who tries to make it work in the
American
Revolution my second point is we're all
over the responsibility deal now there's
a whole wave of that stuff coming and we
are actually right now depreciating
rights in the name of responsibility now
I mean Obama had Cass sunstein you guys
know
him he's a sweetie and uh and you know I
Tom West and I have debated that guy a
couple times at American Political
Science Association meetings and have
you ever been to one of
those gracious sakes but um uh uh he
thinks that uh the government has to
allocate the right to speak because the
underprivileged don't get enough time to
speak see and so he's he's appointed
under Obama's first term and he accepts
the title regulatory
Zar first of all this talk of Zars in
the United States of America is just a
very bad
idea and Republicans are guilty of it
too
but second the regulatories are and he's
saying well you know we're going to have
to give people a bit of a
nudge you know my college has been
getting nudges from them
lately and we don't like
it because they're telling us what to
say and what to
think but that's an explicit Doctrine
and then on the other hand what about
responsibility aren't you preached that
constantly about the destructive effects
of every advantage that you earn for
yourself or win in any way isn't that
forever and ever a thing and so now you
know look look
we've on in the college
business you guys all you know you're in
the college business a lot of you right
what is it like first of all they show
up and they're 18 and it's the most
magical thing in the world but they
don't know anything you know they're
just they're fully capable human beings
they just don't have any experience
that's what's Magic about it right
they're great you just have to love them
and then you watch them grow up right
and then it's like you got 40 or 50 Sons
and Daughters just among the ones who
you get to know really
well so how do you get them to behave
themselves I already said you get them
to agree and one thing about it is it's
a really good idea if they have to to
say good night before they go to
bed you know cuz their bodies are
running wild and put them all up
together I think they'll get to fooling
around and and you know they do anyway
but not as much and also with that
institution in place and with the
requirement that everybody treat
everybody else
civil then you get a lot less of them
assaulting each
other but what if on the other hand
you've got a license to have sex however
you please then you're going to have to
substitute something else for the moral
code that sex has to do with marriage
and children and we're busy substituting
that something else right now aren't we
all the
time and so I don't think we've
forgotten about rights or
responsibilities today I think we're
just busy redefining them and and I
think that these redefinitions are not
likely to work very well and lead to
despotism that's what I think whereas
the old things what they lead to is
self-government go around here and ask
the students who are here tonight or or
you know the Press does this all the
time you might as well do it tweet and
ask people who hate who go to hillso ca
and hate it to put up tweets about
it right and you don't get many
in fact you don't get any and why is
that because they're free and they're
treated like free people and the freedom
is only valuable because it carries
responsibilities with it and then they
can and see don't you don't you see the
Magic in the young I was describing to
somebody today if you write me a letter
some student will open it and read it
and decide whether I should see it and
draft an answer to it and I'm the
president of the college right somebody
sends dirty letters to Hillsdale College
they send them to me and students in the
college read those first up in my office
it's cheap and uh and then they will
come and ask you and we give them places
of responsibility right and then once in
a while they'll stick their head in my
office and say Dr R how do you want me
to do this and I and I always replied
the same word I always say
successfully right and then they go and
then they go oh okay you know in other
words I'm telling them it's your job you
go figure it out and see that's freedom
and it carries a cost nobody fails to
see that who's got any
sense take the cost away which is what
the modern entitlement and Regulatory
state is working on and you take the
freedom away
too
okay uh one more any more usually you
guys shut me up quicker than this so
we'll have one more we'll have two more
there two guys who want to say something
I'll answer briefly oh that's a kid I'm
Spencer Roth fist I'm 16 years old live
here in Omaha Nebraska I just want to
know um based on what you know now which
seems to be quite a bit what is
something so thank you Spencer I I'll
let you finish the question but I just
want to assert there are two things you
should be aware of one is I'm 63 years
old so I've had more time and the other
is you got no idea of the truth of
anything I've been
saying well my question is um what is
one thing you wish you would have known
when you were my age that you know now
and what would you have done different
because of
it uh I almost joined the military uh
somebody in the military talked me out
of it I would have done it if I had do
over I'd do it um
uh there's that me and four buddies of
mine Chris flry the zusa guy whoever he
was right we went down to join the Navy
and be in the reserves and uh we all
took the test and you know we're all a
bunch of almost phds and we're and to
tell you how stupid we were right we
were really stupid we were graduate
students and we were founding The
Claremont Institute and we were joining
the Navy all at the same time
those go together you know and uh I got
talked out of it and I wish I hadn't now
um so that's one thing but the other
thing is I've been very lucky and uh why
I uh almost went to law school I met
this great teacher and decided to get an
education
instead I got a I got I got bitten by a
dog I have a you know I had boxers and
before I had Penny the boxers were mean
you know cuz I didn't care I thought it
was really cool I have a little scar
right here from breaking up a dog fight
and I was laid up for a while I treated
it with other dog medicine that I had I
treated myself but I was house sitting
for a guy who'd written his doctoral
thesis on
Churchill and I thought you know I read
the world crisis I read there's six
volumes I read them through in bed in
two weeks weeks and then I read most of
the
maror and I never stopped and that was
such a blessing and then I got a rotary
fellowship and I went to England and I
met Martin Gilbert and then two weeks
later he hired Penelope
hton so chance has been my friend big
time so I don't have any complaints
except that
yeah I think you should have ended with
Spencer yeah
um you you you ended by saying that uh
Churchill had a fight on his hands and
we probably have one as well uh I'm
curious what you would um curious how
you would apply uh Romans 13 I think
most of us are aware of the um the
dictum in Romans 13 to submit yourself
because there is no Authority except
that which is established by God um some
of you some of some people in this room
probably also aware of uh the Mayu
sermon from I think 1752 about at least
his interpretation of what Romans 13
means on the other side of that I have a
dear friend who uh graduated from weaton
um uh you know I I think that's probably
another respectable institution um and
he his argument is that Romans 13 was
written to people who were living under
tyranny and the message to them was to
uh not combat um but instead to to live
as good citizens um so I I'm just
curious so in answering you if I answer
that he's wrong I have to attack wheat
college is
that I didn't mean to I didn't mean
ready to
do I I didn't mean to set up that uh
that conflict um but I'm curious what
you know the the founders obviously felt
that there was a time when evils become
insufferable and that that that is the
time to um that there is a duty at that
point to throw off such government so
I'm curious where you because my
students ask me the same thing all the
time okay so where's the line um at what
point are evils insufferable what Point
as a time to take up arms against our
your oppressor and so I'm curious where
you're uh how how do we apply Romans 13
and um and uh you know which which of
those okay so I can address that so um
did any of you see there's I wish I had
the text of it here to read to you
there's some old judge from the 19th
century in Alabama who answers a
question from a constituent about
alcohol and he says if you mean alcohol
and it goes on like this it's better
then I can reproduce from memory but he
says you mean the destroyer of families
the sapper of energy the wrecker of
careers then I'm against it and if you
mean alcohol the lubricant of
conversation
said so my position is like that
position right so I believe that Romans
13 should be strictly observed and I
believe also that the example of the
Apostles when they're dragged before the
Sanhedrin in order not to teach the
faith must also be strictly observed and
you may recall that their answer to them
was you give the orders that you want we
have to do what we're going to do and I
think this the Bible is written that way
and I will even tell you my reading of
it and I don't put myself forward here
as as a clerical guide to anybody in the
room just a Christian Fellow who's been
reading it a long time I'm thinking
about it and think about it as it
relates to politics in particular
um what I think is going on in the in
the New Testament is something
unprecedented like so many things about
God and about
Jesus that uh leads to our country and
all of us sitting here because what's
odd about
him uh from the point of view of things
I study it's it's simply breathtaking
and unique and unimagined before him so
before him what you've got is you've got
the ancient city and their gods who are
particular gods of of the city and then
you've got the Jews who claim a
universal God who's also a political God
but not everybody's political God just
for the chosen people and then the
people who lead the Jews are generals
and commanders and courts and judges and
all that the whole apparatus of
government and so the thought is among
many is that when the Messiah comes he
will be like them we'll get these Romans
out of here and we'll get to run our
poity again and then the astonishing
thing about Jesus is my kingdom is not
of this world and yet he's to be
everybody's God everywhere in fact the
single most important thing the claim is
by Jesus is that you regardless where
you are and who you are and what your
circumstances are or when you live You
Must Believe on me on Peril of your
Immortal
soul and yet I'm not providing a bunch
of laws for
you and so there's a long history that
begins in the New Testament about what
what does that mean for governance and
so the the New Testament text speak on
both sides of that question and I think
what it has to do with myself as my
reading of it is what they're saying to
people is you don't get to govern
anybody because you're a
Christian doesn't mean you're not still
a
citizen I think it means that and I
think that those text May sense when you
read them in a row which I have done
many times if you think of it like that
now all of a
sudden first of all there's a kind of
regime that is described in Acts but
also in Matthew show me a Denarius he
says whose picture Render unto Caesar
what is Caesar's unto God what is God do
you understand that's an act of
rebellion because Caesar claimed the
authority to decide which is
which and that means that that's a
demotion of
Caesar so I can tell you the people who
founded our country thought long and
hard about that stuff go read a preacher
from Massachusetts called Samuel West
who among other honors was picked by by
uh John
Adams to give the sermon that lasted 2
hours on the day they voted to implement
the constitution of the state of
Massachusetts and it is a work of art
about just those subjects I was talking
about and the founders just loved that
guy and it was a kind of muscular
Christianity but it was also very
devout
thanks
[Applause]